why did Taylor Swift not want to perform
at the Super Bowl like why would a pop
star turn down a Super Bowl halftime
show oh apparently they don't pay you
but also she seems like she's no fun
[ __ ] her reasoning was that she's still
in the process of recording all of her
albums again that makes sense made made
it through only a few and wants to wait
to go through all of them then
completely on her music again do you
want to explain why she's doing that
basically her library was sold and in
order to be able to control your music
again you re-record your Masters which
is unheard of you know it's like saying
like Paul McCartney go re-record an
album
being owned by somebody is the recording
in which they purchased it's not the
song
it's that recording of the song
so
and maybe they own it for like a few
years after that or something like that
so you can re-record that song
and then own that version of it yeah I
think they own that recording I assume
into perpetuity and then so you just say
all right well I'm gonna do it according
to here's my record and then you're this
is the one we're gonna put on Spotify
right yeah this is the one I'm gonna
sell that sponsors
which is a brilliant move on her part no
Big Brand Unilever is not gonna to go
around Taylor and buy the other music
for the same price well here's what's
going to happen next
she's gonna [ __ ] artists out of being
able to do this
because now every new contract is we own
this song yeah in perpetuity right right
right because I imagine the old
contracts were just like oh yeah we own
the song it is what it is you're not
going to re-record the song like that
looks in bad faith now it's we own this
intellectual property that's us but
maybe you can charge more for it and
maybe yeah but like could I do that
where I record a Disney song and then
put it out and then I cover some famous
Disney song and then get paid from the
streams from that song yeah yeah like do
you have to get covers cleared yeah I
mean but you'll still have to pay payout
to the original song maker if you have
permission from them yeah you're saying
could you do it without their permission
yeah like how because she's basically
covering her own music
look it's the same thing like you could
play a song from somebody in the club
you're on tour you can play a Taylor
Swift song she could come for you or the
record label could probably come from
like hey you're making money off of my
right like if you but there's still
cover bands I just don't think people
make that but the company that owns her
Masters could they come to her and be
like oh you're covering something that
we own that no because all they own is
that recording of the song so does
Disney just own that recording of The
Little Mermaid what if they own the
intellectual property of The Little
Mermaid I think I think the artist which
is her she owns the intellectual
property of the song uh but maybe the
writer that helped her also owns gets a
piece of that maybe she needs to get
their permission but she's known for
writing her own [ __ ] so she like made
the song doesn't the producer own a
piece too yeah producer gets yeah okay
so she's gonna use the same producers do
the same thing it depends I don't know
if she's gonna get the same producers
but how much work is that a [ __ ] ton of
work is it yeah because she Just Gotta
Sing the song she sings anyway
Unwritten you don't sing the same you
and you also have every single beat
needs to be redone so like say if it was
live instrumentation like now this
person has to learn how to play that
song like and you want it to sound good
you don't want it to be like yeah
this is a validity because in my mind
it's like you can't take three weeks off
no no it takes a long time you don't
think that they're you don't think she's
upset that she would have to share the
spotlight with other artists I don't
yeah I tend to you think the worship
Taylor Swift all the time yeah I think
it's a great business play it's like nah
let me own all my [ __ ] so then when I do
go on a Super Bowl and have another run
and everybody's listening to my music
listening to my new [ __ ] she doesn't
want to get that super bowl bump and
then they're all playing her old [ __ ]
interesting yeah so that makes perfect
and then as far as like Rihanna taking
it there was such a there's so much hype
around it and I couldn't really figure
out why it's three on it yeah because
you know what like I don't think that
Rihanna's big but I'm like she's she's
like Michael Jackson did this like Jimi
Hendrix like every Big musician does a
Super Bowl yeah that was Michael Jackson
was 30 years ago yeah but like Jimi
Hendrix is long Dead who did it last
night long dead did the Super Bowl by
the way I think so I don't know I think
he did Woodstock oh yeah maybe I don't
think it'll win is that different are
you yeah Prince yeah um
right yeah yeah oh yeah again 15 years
ago yeah yeah but I'm like what is the
issue with Rihanna doing it why I feel
so people just love Rihanna people love
Rihanna she's like they were here they
get a huge act and every year people
getting signed for the commercials oh
what do you mean she hasn't put out an
album in almost like I think almost 10
years now Rihanna it's been so long
until I was out that's a good point and
she doesn't talk and now it's like holy
spirit about Rihanna it's really
exciting they whoever's managing her and
I'm not talking about like
Jay-Z manages Rihanna whatever I'm
talking about whoever's day-to-day
crafting her career has done a [ __ ]
awesome job I mean she's a billionaire
yeah she's I think it's more so just her
because she's like she went out on a
banger of an album like the last album
that she put out was like crazy instant
classic everybody loved it yeah and so
and then she had the Fenty and like so
the makeup and then the clothes that
[ __ ] blew she's bigger than music yeah
so now it's like she's making so much
more money from the other [ __ ] it's like
where's the motivation to still do music
yeah acoustic it's like you gotta bust
your ass you got to learn these the
[ __ ] choreography you gotta go travel
places like yeah I could just make one
you know I see two things is that bigger
than music she's like a mogul icon
whatever you want to say and she's still
culturally relevant yeah the Super Bowl
has not had both of those things Dr Dre
bigger than music sure probably a
billionaire whatever yeah Beyonce 2013
was a big deal this is not the only time
we've gotten excited about the super
bowl half time show I don't know if you
know this it's been a big deal before
yeah yeah I just don't know I'm like
every time they get a big person and
every time it's a good show and I'm like
but for this time it's like I cannot
believe they got free I'm like why
they've unloaded money
no nobody's excited that they can't
believe they got Rihanna they're just
excited to see Rihanna yeah and they
don't pay you for the record yeah but go
on YouTube you can Google and tell at
least maybe they changed it very
recently but you don't see a lot until
very recently they did not get paid and
also like Rihanna if you look at her
hits she has the greatest collabs so she
should be able to get Jay-Z Kanye she
should be able to [ __ ] but that's
what makes those shows the best the
perfect perfect guests for the Super
Bowl because the songs are amazing she's
got a million [ __ ] hits to choose
from she has ones that she obviously no
yeah she has every different genre like
I don't think that there's a I hate
Rihanna music person out there no every
person likes yourself right like you
said she has the house [ __ ] she's got r
b she's got hip hop like it satisfies
everything there's probably even like a
rock no there is a rock there's a
country song with um
[Laughter]
yeah and Kanye so that's not it's not
really country but it is like acoustic
uh
[Laughter]